there were signs that this guy should
not have had a gun just like I believe
that people that have um are domestic
violence offenders should not have G one
time on this program I gave the women of
The View Credit today is not that day
respond to you um Sarah I I sorry Maine
was where the shooting was I said
Massachusetts Maine and they and they
don't have red flag Lads and and I I
hear what you're saying and there were
signs that this guy should not have had
a gun just like I believe that people
that have um are domestic violence
offenders should not have that was just
rolled back in Texas domers can have gun
but I'm kind of worried about
stigmatizing people with mental health
because when you look at the statistics
people that suffer from mental health
are much more likely to be the victim of
a violent CRI I'm not I know this answer
though I have mental illness problems I
have anxiety problems I have depression
problems I'm not saying everyone that's
ever gone to a therap or on medication
he was hearing voices that were telling
him what to do I think everyone in this
room can agree that's mental
problem schizophrenic told people he was
going to go shoot up a base so he told
us that and it's important to notice
those details but I got go got to go
we'll be right
back